good morning Hank it's Thursday we left
off yesterday in our study of the French
Revolution in early 1793 with King Louie
xvi being separated from his head via
guillotine and France is ensuing war
with almost all of Europe meanwhile and
I don't want to overemphasize this no
one has done anything to fix the famine
so these poor laborers known as the sons
culottes because they wore pants instead
of shorts or humorous outfits they start
rioting and eventually these guys and
the Jacobins get an idea to solve the
famine which is even worse than the idea
of going to war with Austria government
price controls for bread this of course
fails miserably and eventually having
failed at stealing grain from the rest
of Europe the French government sends
its army into the countryside to steal
grain from itself all this happened
under the leadership of the Committee of
Public Safety motto we suck at
protecting public safety which was then
by maximilien robespierre a
fascinatingly paranoid despot who would
foreshadow fascinatingly paranoid despot
s' like Kim jong-il and Saddam Hussein
and Joseph Stalin rope spear the
Committee of Public Safety hated anyone
associated in any way with the church or
the royalty and between the summers of
1793 and 1794 they oversaw the
guillotining of more than 16 thousand
people including many nobility many
inadequately revolutionary
revolutionaries clergy who refused to
sign an oath to the government and of
course in October Marie Antoinette Marie
Antoinette the King's wife who for the
record never said let them eat cake and
who like almost everyone murdered during
the terror posed absolutely no threat to
the government so what had just recently
been the first and second estates of
France the people who ran the show had
suddenly become the enemies of this new
secular state and in the end this led to
a lasting decline in the relevance of
religion and class to governments and
economies in Europe the rampant
guillotining during the terror is often
seen as an example of enlightenment
thinking run amok but in fact more
people were killed by guns during the
terror than by the guillotine so ya know
however among the people killed by the
guillotine was Robespierre who after a
year of being paranoid that people were
trying to
kill him of course inevitably got
himself killed which is one of the great
lessons of history and also life if you
act out of a paranoid fear of something
happening you will always make that
thing happen right so Robespierre was
guillotined in the month of Thermidor in
the year - oh that reminds me of
something I forgot to mention which is
that while there was this famine going
on and France was broken fighting like
nine Wars the Committee of Public Safety
decided to change the French calendar
you know because the traditional
calendar with its 24-hour days and it's
dating from the birth of Christ was all
irrational and religion II they renamed
all the months and decided that every
day would only have ten hours and every
hour 100 minutes that would be an
example of enlightenment thinking run
amok so after the committee collapsed
France passed a new constitution and for
the next four years from 1795 to 1799
France was run by a group of directors
who stole elections and bungled the
economy but didn't cut off sixteen
thousand people's heads so bonus points
for them but the French military was
actually having a lot of success largely
because in 1793 France instituted the
first military draft which meant they
had way more soldiers than anybody else
and really the military was the only
institution in which people had
confidence which is why when General
Napoleon Bonaparte seized power in 1799
people were initially pretty psyched and
so it was that after more than a hundred
thousand lives lost a decade of
suffering a continent-wide war France
went from one supreme ruler to another
the best quote ever about the French
Revolution comes from the former Chinese
President Joe Enlai who in the 1960s was
asked what he thought the french
revolutions impact had been and he
answered it's too soon to say and in a
way it still is the french revolution
brought to the fore many of the
conflicts that continue to define
modernity between secularism and
religion between idealism and pragmatism
between oligarchy and democracy and to
answer the inevitable student question
of why we even have to study this stuff
that would be my first answer the past
isn't past it's still shaping the
present but even more than that I
believe that the study of history is
essentially an exercise in empathy you
have to imagine what it was like to be a
peasant in eighteenth century
or to be king louis xvi or to be marie
antoinette or robes pierre looking good
what the study of history forces you to
confront is how people who are acting
rationally who think they're acting in
their own best interest and in many
cases think they're acting in the best
interest of their countries can end up
killing so many people and in many cases
killing themselves i believe that
thinking about those questions makes us
better at living our little lives even
if it is in a less fancy costume in my
case a much less fancy costume hey I'll
see you on Friday
you